the name of this operation of the Hamas
operation is alaka flood referring to
the aloa mosque how much of this attack
is about the alaka
mosque in actuality I don't think any of
it is but The alaka Masque is is
something that uh all of the uh Shia
jihadists have used for years in order
to justify their actions that are
aggressive towards Israel so so uh this
is something I'll maybe even take a step
back and go through when I was working
uh initially in my first year on the
peace plan I was doing a lot of
listening and quite frankly a lot of
what people were saying to me didn't
make sense and the reason why I was
trying to figure out they were talking
about uh sovereignty over alaka mosque
the alaka mosque is a mosque that's
built in the holy of holies the Haram Al
Sharif uh in Israel where the the Jewish
betam mdash the Holy Temple was built in
a very religious place about
after the temple was destroyed um then
there was a big mosque built there and
it's one of the more uh holy places in
Islam uh now so uh so the big uh thing
everyone was saying is what do you do
with this land where you have a mosque
built over a very big Jewish site and I
was hearing all of the experts and you
know I always say experts with quotes
because only in Washington can you work
on something for a decade and continue
to fail and then you basically leave and
are considered an expert um but that's
one of the problems with Washington
which maybe we could talk about later
but the notion here was I went and I
said let me try to understand what the
issue is with the Israeli Palestinian
conflict with the people right I always
felt the politicians were a little
disconnected so I commissioned several
focus groups one in in Aman one in Cairo
One in Dubai and one in rala and I asked
you know people U
Muslims what is the is Arab what is the
Israeli Palestinian conflict about M and
time and time again the most popular
thing that they said was that Israel was
not allowing access to the mosque for
Muslims to pray and what was interesting
was is that Israel's policy is to allow
anyone who wants to come and pray
peacefully at the SES to come and pray
sometimes they have security issues when
there's provocations um but by and large
since 1967 when Israel um was able to
take back Jerusalem in a defensive War
just to be very clear they were attacked
um in the South and they were attacked
uh uh from from the East
and they basically were able to beat
back the jordanians and the Egyptians
and and then reconquer the old city of
Jerusalem and during that time
immediately after uh Israel then passed
the protection of holy places law which
was they basically took resources they
didn't have and they said we're going to
uh restore the Christian sites the
Muslim sites the the Jewish sites and
they've worked to allow everyone access
to the mosque so today um any Muslim who
wants to come can come and pray at the
mosque uh the mosque is um Israel's
acknowledge that King Abdullah uh the
King of Jordan uh is uh is the custodian
of of the mosque and as long as people
want to come to the country and pray
peacefully they're able to do that but
if you look at a lot of the propaganda
that's been used by ISIS or Iran to uh
to recruit um uh terrorists or to
justify their incursions they often say
they're doing it in the name of
liberating the aloa mosque but from an
operational and pragmatic uh perspective
today any Muslim who wants to go to the
mosque you can book a flight to Israel
now through Dubai because there's
flights between Israel and Dubai and if
as long as your country has relations
with Israel and they'll accept your
passport in there you can come and pray
and that's what Israel wants Israel
wants Jerusalem to be a place where all
religions can come and celebrate
together but you have a lot of actors
that look to find ways to use these
religious tensions uh in order to sew
Division and justify violent
Behavior I wonder how it's possible to
lessen the effectiveness of that
propaganda
message that a lot of the war a lot of
the attacks about access to the alaka
mask is there something you can speak to
why that message hasn't disseminated
across the the Arab world so Israel is
good at a lot of things they're not very
good traditionally with public relations
um you know after the Abraham Accords
you know we made the first Abraham
Accords deal in August 2020 and then we
made uh five other deals we first did uh
United Arab imates then we did a deal
with Bahrain then we did a deal with uh
Kosovo then we did a deal with um with
Sudan then we did a deal with Morocco um
and then we got the GCC deal done as
well the deal the the tension between
Qatar Saudi UAE Egypt and Bahrain and
that was allowing us to create a pathway
to then pursue the Israeli Saudi
normalization so we had so much momentum
then that the goal was just keep getting
more countries to normalize relations
with Israel uh once you create the
connection between people and create the
ability for people to do business
together the ability for flights to fly
between then you would just start
naturally having people coming and
everyone has a smartphone today so they
can then post and combat the uh the
misinformation that's been out there but
this misinformation is not something
that's new you know one of the
characters who played a very big role in
in spreading the anti-Semitism and the
violence and uh in Israel in the 1920s
was a guy named Haj Amin Al husseini who
was a known as the grand Muti of jerus M
he was very close with Hitler and melini
and he was working with them to try to
get some claims to the Middle East once
the Jewish people were annihilated and
what he did for a very long time was he
did the same shtick only it was before
he had smartphones and YouTube where he
would say the mosque is under in attack
these imperialist zionists are coming in
to try to destroy the mosque and he
would use that to raise money from
Indonesia from uh Pakistan from all over
the world and then use that that threat
to justify recruiting you know groups of
young vulnerable Muslim men and and then
you know getting them in the name of of
religious rights to go and kill people
which is not which really is more of a
perversion of the religion than I think
the true essence of what Islam is I
think Islam at its core is a peaceful
religion and I think that's where a lot
of the great leaders in Islam want to
take it but the people who use Islam or
the the mosque or as a justification for
violence those are people who I think
are are really um they are disrespecting
the the Islam
religion